-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Beto O'Rourke.
You mentioned, and I don't
want to just pass over it
without talking about exactly
how awful it is.
But Governor Abbott made it --
Basically the state of Texas
investigating parents who
provide gender-affirming care
to their children,
basically investigating them
for child abuse.
You went on Mother's Day
and you made dinner for
one of these families.
-I did.
-Played a little music,
as I know you like to do.
And can you just tell us, you
know -- and I'm sorry that
so much of this is so
depressing, but can you tell us,
what is it like for a family
like that,
to be basically
almost criminalized
for being a loving parent?
-First thing I'll tell you is,
I've met families like
the Briggles all over the state
of Texas,
and these parents are
the most loving parents
you'll find anywhere.
They're doing their best to help
their kid navigate
this incredibly difficult time
in their lives,
and they're searching
for answers,
just loving the hell
out of them,
just trying to make sure that
they're okay.
And our governor, Greg Abbott,
is proposing charging them
with child abuse.
And if that charge is sustained,
not only taking their trans kid
from them,
but every other child
in the household,
placing them in a foster-care
system in Texas
that is the worst-run
in the country,
where 100 kids in that system
died last year in the custody
and the care of
the state of Texas.
Instead of fixing that system
and the vulnerable kids
that are in it, he's going to
take these kids
from their loving parents
and put them there.
So I wanted to show up on
Mother's Day, cook a great meal,
bring some flowers, have a beer,
and just make sure that we
shined a light on
this loving family
so that our fellow Texans
understand what's at stake.
I mean, they might lose what I
take for granted
with Amy and our three kids,
and I want to make sure that we
fight for them and fight for
everybody who's under attack
in Texas right now.
So showing up for them
and standing up for them
was important.
-That's really great
that you did that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, happy to.
-Let's be honest.
How was the dinner you made?
What do you think?
-It was great.
The one thing I can make really
well is a diner-style hamburger
where you press the beef
down into the pan.
Some Velveeta cheese slices.
-Okay, gotcha.
-My wife, Amy, added this twist
where we use an English muffin
instead of a regular bun.
Mayonnaise and a raw onion
on it.
Just all of that together is
just amazing.
-Do you use their pan?
Did you use their pan
or did you bring your own?
-We were cooking for so many
people that we used
their cast iron,
and I bought a cast iron
and donated it to the house
as well.
-Okay, that's fair. That's cool.
-We didn't want to show up
empty-handed.
-No, that's true.
-Yeah.
-If you showed up at our house,
my wife would not let you
near our pans.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, you know, somebody
who was talking about
and then ultimately decided
against running for governor
of Texas was
Matthew McConaughey,
who is a friend of the show.
Would there be room for Matthew
to do something
in an O'Rourke administration,
if you won?
-Absolutely.
-Yeah.
-This guy's a great Texan.
Beyond being
an extraordinary actor,
when the chips are down in
our state, this guy shows up.
So, we had a horrific shooting
in El Paso in 2019.
23 people were killed
after Greg Abbott, Donald Trump,
and others warned of
this invasion of Mexicans
and immigrants who were
coming to get us.
McConaughey showed up to
El Paso, raised money,
donated it to the community,
was there,
you know, physically present
to make sure
that we all knew
that he was with us.
When we had this winter storm
last year
and Abbott couldn't keep the
lights on, the power went off,
hundreds died, tens of billions
of dollars of damage,
McConaughey gets all of his
famous friends together,
and they raise millions of
dollars for the state.
So this guy is there for Texas
and he's got such
an amazing heart,
so whatever he wants to do
and whoever he can help,
we want to turn him loose
and let him do that.
But he's an example of
the spirit of the state.
I don't know if the guy is
a Republican or a Democrat,
and it doesn't matter
because before we're either
of those things,
we're Texans, we're Americans,
we're human beings,
and we should start treating
one another that way.
And so we're going to do that
in Texas.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You have often --
Attention has been paid to
the fact that you really --
you know, it's a giant state,
and you get out and you drive
around and you go to places
that maybe people
who run for governor
don't ever stop by.
Is that the plan
this time again?
I know you were a little --
You know, during COVID,
the way you organize, the way
you ran elections in the past
wasn't available
in the same way.
Is it nice to be back out there
seeing Texans face-to-face?
-I love it.
I love being on the road.
I love showing up in communities
where they maybe don't
expect you.
So you're going to expect us
in Austin and Houston, Dallas,
El Paso, my hometown,
San Antonio,
the Rio Grande Valley.
But you show up in Childress,
Shamrock, Texas, Pampa,
where Woody Guthrie
spent some time,
Dalhart, Amarillo, San Angelo.
These places are so red,
you can see them glowing
from outer space as you are
orbiting the planet,
but they're also unrepresented
because where Democrats
fear to tread,
Republicans don't have to
show up and contest the vote.
And so folks don't have anyone
to hold accountable,
anyone to share their hopes with
or their concerns.
When we show up and hold
a town hall, I learn so much,
but I also build support
and trust in that community,
and we bring in some more votes.
And at the end of the day,
I mean, we lost to Ted Cruz
by 2 1/2 and a half points,
right?
There are millions more Texans
who've since been added
to the rolls
and millions who've been
effectively,
through voter suppression,
kept from voting.
We're targeting those who've
been the targets of
intimidation and suppression
so that they provide
the margin of victory
when we win this thing
on November 8th.
So I love traveling the state.
It's the right way to do it.
And I think it's the only way
to win.
-Well, you know, stay healthy
out there.
I know it probably takes a lot
out of you.
And thanks so much for making
time for us today.
-Thank you.
I really, really appreciate it.
-Guys, that's Beto O'Rourke.